[Music]
that's not a knife that's a knife that's
me
Brian Dundee really yeah really
how do you keep saying really draw their
might nothing to see here man just get
the clean shane with my my [ __ ] - Barry
you know when you dad did it he was he
was mocking and well my dad told me
about this he was just like yeah I just
came up and you did this okay I just
don't think you can see you from back
here not a lot of Crocs out here huh
this is 37,000 miles of pristine
beautiful beach mate did you know that
Australia makes some of the finest wines
in the entire world
I didn't hear that
very much
wait hold up this isn't a movie no it's
tourism ad for Australia yes but listen
to you the best Crocodile Dundee since
Crocodile Dundee really yes really and
we had the best trip ever didn't we
it was pretty sweet
[Music]
heyyo there are some great flaunt deals
with trolley around there dude I get it
it's not a movie it's a commercial
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
today losers yo with the tech rosette
Brian Dundee yep
yeah really I think you saying really
what do you mean done days lost in the
outback
he is the other you know everybody talks
about Mick like that definitely that
North might finish off nice how big
you mean his - you have a saint a
humpback whale get that it's a bloodbath
speak to me little guy well my dad told
me about this he was just like yeah I
just came up and you did they bit day at
this okay I just don't think you can see
you from back here
I don't just on this newspaper son I in
this country I'm done Dee's gonna learn
who the most dangerous animal in
Australia is it's me whatever
[Music]
[Applause]
my mom's side of the family are all jazz
musicians so kind of comes natural to me
whoa
[Music]
I think it's working Mike you're
disturbing my mind energies you can't
speak when I'm doing this okay it's
gotta be super quiet just a connection
between me and the Beast okay here we go
please don't say anything would I do it
this time okay yep oh yeah it could just
sense that you're about to say something
and that's already trying to mess up all
the brain energy stuff okay okay I just
don't think he can see you from back
here should we just go around maybe
whatever
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
good day losers that's not a knife
that's a knife leave that look at me
look at the knife plan
[Music]
yo will them take rosette Brian Dundee
yep
really yeah really yeah really
why do you keep saying really
you